>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Rae Armantrout teaches writing
and literature at the University
of California, San Diego.
Her most recent book, Burst,
merited the unusual trifecta
of wining the Pulitzer
Prize in 2010,
the National Book Critics Circle
Award as well as being a finalist
for the National Book Award.
This comes at a point in a
prolific career boasting 10 volumes
of poetry, here's Burst.
She is only the third poet to have
won these two awards in one year.
And to quote a recent
New Yorker article,
the most genuinely experimental
poet to get the Pulitzer
since John Ashbury won
the triple crown in 1976.
On the surface, these poems
appear modest and contained
and resemble those of
William Carlos Williams.
Perhaps unassumingly simple,
her poems are what the Pulitzer
Prize committee characterized
as little thought bombs.
They tick in your brain, you
see the word play and virtuosity
and sophistication there, showing
off what the art of poetry can do.
They pulse with intelligence.
She is a high practitioner
of the art.
These poems do not sit, they do
not settle, they do not behave.
They sparkle with hard, brilliant
surfaces, reflecting our lives.
These poems address matter and time,
existence, metaphysics with wit --
when I'm metaphorical, I'm happy,
she quips -- and make us realize --
these poems make us realize
these big questions exist
in every waking moment.
Why is sleep's border
guarded, or, how the feeling
of emptiness is a preexisting
condition,
or been aware of the
bitter symbiosis of couples.
It is provocative work
about the exhausting
and exhilarating moments
of our lives.
Her poems are very quotable,
but I will stop there,
although it's tempting,
because we have the privilege
of having her with us today.
Welcome, Rae Armantrout.
[ Applause ]
>> Rae Armantrout: Thank you.
Those introductions
are always so daunting.
And I was also very daunted when I
was told that I was expected to talk
and not just read, because poets are
accustomed to giving readings and,
you know, maybe interspersing
the poems with a few remarks,
but not actually talking.
Now, I need to put this down.
But, so -- I'm prepared
to talk a little bit,
and then I'm going
to read some poems.
And I wanted to start by saying
that there's a real sense
in which I shouldn't be here, in
which it's amazing that I'm here.
Well, two reasons, actually.
First, I grew up in a world
where literature was a
very distant reality.
People sometimes say
I came from nothing,
but it's never quite like that.
My parents were from Missouri,
rural southern Missouri
in my mother's case.
My father was a chief
petty officer in the Navy.
I think it's a bit unfortunate
when you have the word
petty in your title.
Like -- I don't know
why the Navy does that.
So, I was raised in San
Diego, where I live now.
I mean, how boring is that?
And first in Navy housing, and then
in a housing tract called
Allied Gardens, which was,
as the name implies,
essentially a tract built
to house veterans returning
from the Second World War.
It was a white, working-class
suburb, deliberately invented
for these returning veterans.
I only recently read, really, in
Mike Davis's book on San Diego,
Under a Perfect Sun, that those
loans way back in the day,
were available to white
veterans only.
Allied Gardens was pretty much
on the eastern edge of San Diego
at that time, so, far
from the beach,
no beach boys, no surfer culture.
I didn't meet anyone who was an
artist while I was growing up.
Once, a teacher tried to
introduce me to a woman
who wrote greeting cards.
That was it.
That was about as close as
I came to seeing a poet.
But, nonetheless, my mother
did actually, I think,
begin my interest in poetry.
She had a children -- she bought a
children's encyclopedia called Child
Craft that -- I mean,
encyclopedias now are
such a distant artifact already.
They don't exist anymore, you know?
Now you just have the internet.
You look things up on Google.
Google's the encyclopedia, right?
But, so this couldn't happen now.
But then, there was this anthology,
this encyclopedia for children,
and two of the volumes
were devoted to poetry.
And somehow I was captivated by
that, partly by the illustrations,
I have to admit, but partly by
the cadences and the images.
There was Lewis Carroll, of course,
but somehow the editors
had also seen fit
to include some Emily Dickinson.
You know, little bits, the
ones that seemed tamer.
I remember one that started:
The morns are a meeker now.
And ended up, you know:
I'll put a trinket on.
She was trying to match --
she was ironically trying to
match the grandeur of nature
by putting on a little trinket.
My mother's favorite was called
When the Frost is on the Punkin,
which reminded her
of Missouri, I guess.
When I went to school,
then I was lucky again,
because I had a first grade
teacher who loved poetry
and she got us to make
up little poems.
And she bound them in
a mimeographed book.
And then my seventh grade teacher
is the one I really have to thank,
if indeed thanking is appropriate
to people who turn you into a poet
because some people would
think that's exactly
where you want to end up.
But, this teacher gave me the
Louis Untermeyer Anthology
of Modern American Poetry.
And it was there that I
discovered T. S. Elliot
and William Carlos Williams.
Like all young teenagers, I read
The Hollow Men -- maybe not all --
but I read The Hollow Men and
went: Yeah, they're all hollow.
So, you know, now I think
it's not that simple.
But then that was my teenage
response and I loved that.
And then when I was 18, I
went to the local college,
which was San Diego
State, and met my husband.
That was about 1966, say.
And I bet you can imagine
what comes next?
What comes next is we
started hearing more and more
about a country about Viet Nam.
The boy who grew up across the
street from me went there and died.
And I certainly didn't want that
to happen to my new boyfriend,
to whom I'm still married.
So, we began to listen to the
justifications that were being made
for that war, which are a
lot like the justifications
that are still made for wars.
And we got our first taste of
spin, what we now call spin,
that is concentrations
camps were captured,
Vietnamese were called
freedom hamlets.
And people spoke about having
to destroy a village
in order to save it.
And that sense that words can
be manipulated and can be used
to mislead has stuck with me since.
I think that one good thing
that poetry can do is
it almost forces you
to pay close attention to words.
I mean, that's what you're
doing when you read a poem.
There's not many other
ways to read a poem.
It forces you to kind of slow
down and look at the words.
And I think that's useful,
especially in this age of spin.
I think another thing
that is interesting
about poetry is it takes us back to
that time when we were very young
and we were learning language,
because we were all code
breakers then, right?
We were listening for repetition,
we were listening for patterns,
we were listening for
inflections, and we were trying
to make sense in that way.
And I think we still
approach poetry that way.
And then as we got the feeling
that we were getting the hang
of language, we began
to play with it.
Maybe we started by babbling.
We enjoyed it a lot, we
made language our game.
And I think poets get to still
do that, which is pretty cool.
Not that I'm going to babble,
although you may consider it babble,
but you know, the pure
pleasure of words.
And then as far as my
poems, my particular poems,
I think the introduction mentioned
this, but I often start a poem
when I feel puzzled, when I
have a question I can't answer,
which is what I call
a real question.
Then I try to write my way into it,
and not necessarily to settle it.
I don't -- I like, for myself I
like poetry that leaves unsettled,
that just points where the problem
is, poems that are as much a mystery
as existence is a mystery,
because it is.
So, that's, for me, where
maybe all good literature,
but certainly poems come in.
And then -- so now I'm getting
close to talking about the book
that -- my most recent book.
And that book was partly written
after a very strange
thing happened to me.
I mean, I was writing it,
I had launched into it.
And then I was diagnosed
with a strange kind of cancer
that I had never heard of
before, adrenocortical cancer.
It's extremely rare, so rare
that I've been now asked
to address two medical schools.
So I'm like, you know, I present
my case as -- I'm an exhibit now.
So, you know, I went, what?
But, and then I found out by looking
it up on the internet that it has
like a 5 to 15 percent
survival rate.
And they're talking
about five years.
Well, it's been over four
years now and I don't seem
to be sick, so that also is strange.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you for clapping
for survival, yay!
But being diagnosed with
a deadly disease puts you
in unfamiliar territory, right?
In a very strange state
of mind, which is, oddly,
especially if it stretches out
and you don't die right away
and you're not in terrible pain
-- I was lucky that I wasn't --
you're left with this sense of
the strangeness of your situation,
your estrangement from
the world as you knew it.
And that's not a bad
place from which to write.
So, now I'm -- if I have
time left, and I guess I do,
I'm going to read a few poems.
And I'll start with one that was
written before the diagnosis,
but one which I think talks
about playing with language,
and just the pure pleasure of words
for themselves, in themselves.
And that one is called Scumble.
What if I were turned on
by seemingly innocent words
such as scumble, pinkie,
or extrapolate.
What if I maneuvered
conversation in the hope
that others would pronounce
these words?
Perhaps the excitement would come
from the way the other
person touched them, lightly
and carelessly with his tongue.
What if 'of' were such a hot button?
Scumble of bushes.
What if there were a hidden pleasure
in calling one thing
by another's name.
And there is, I think,
for some reason.
That's what metaphor does.
Okay, then I'm going to skip
to a couple of prose poems
that I wrote shortly after
receiving the diagnosis.
This first one takes most of its
imagery from the Egyptian Book
of the Dead, but it's
not quoting it literally.
On Your Way.
On your way to the sea of reeds, you
will meet the soul devouring demon.
You've heard it all
before, and you believe it.
Why not? Why would they lie?
You must wear the beetle
amulet to avoid being consumed.
But it's also true that
you can't really know
until it's actually happening.
So you have a sort of knowledge
which, even if later confirmed
in each detail, is still
not real knowledge.
He will weigh your heart,
and if it's too heavy,
you will be swallowed up.
What is this extra
element that is mingled
in when you arrive
at the ordained spot?
And this next one is
also a prose poem.
And it was -- I didn't really
write it in a doctor's office,
but I got the idea for it while
I was waiting for the doctor
to come back and tell me
whether my cancer had remerged,
because they were reading
a scan and they were going
to come back and tell me.
Together. Now I am always perched
on a metal examination table.
Two people, a doctor and
a nurse, come at intervals
to tell me whether
I will live or die.
They do this with practiced
solemnity.
They're smug or snug
in their habits,
their relative safety, of course.
But that is to be expected.
And I wait expectantly,
even eagerly,
as if I might be of some help.
If the news is bad, I imagine,
they will direct our attention
to an area of concern.
For a moment, we will lean
together toward that place.
But it would be a short
moment, right?
Then they would go away.
[ Applause ]
And I think that when you're
in a situation like that,
especially as time goes on,
you don't just cry and worry.
You laugh sometimes, too.
So, some of this next one
might be a little funny.
Some of it's based on a dream I had.
Around. Time is pleased
to draw itself out,
permit itself pendulous
loops, to allow them meaning.
This meaning, as it goes along.
Chuck and I are pleased
to have found a spot
where my ashes can be scattered.
It looks like a construction
site now, but it's adjacent
to a breathtaking, rocky coast.
Chuck sees places where
he might snorkel.
We're being shown through
by a sort of realtor.
We're interested, but can't
get her to fix the price.
The future is all around us.
It's a place, anyplace,
where we don't exist.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
The Racket.
It's as if the real thing, your own
absence, can never be uncovered.
Each actor's face seems
to have survived the same brave
battle to remain in character.
They're posed on the rubble
used to indicate the past.
It turns out, this is heaven.
In the present, cancer sets
up a free market in your gut.
The fog lifts, and
the birds start in.
Each works to replace
itself with a bit of racket.
I'm going to take a break from
reading poems about illness.
How much time do I have left?
Okay. Lots of time.
Is that supposed to
include the Q and A?
Okay, then I should
probably stop soon.
I'm going to read one that
doesn't have to do with illness,
it has to do with movies
that you've probably seen.
So these are based
on movie previews.
And the poem's called Previews.
And they are also prose
poems, and each is subtitled.
So the first is subtitled, America.
The playboy scion of a
weapons company repents.
His company, he sees
now, is corrupt,
his weapons being sold behind
his back to strong men.
Alone, he builds a super
weapon in the shape of a man.
Now more powerful and more innocent
than ever before, he attacks.
Happening.
The train halts.
An engineer tells us we're stopped
because we've lost touch
with the outside world.
Things are happening ahead, but
we don't know what they are.
This could represent an act of war.
We stand in a field,
no longer passengers.
All right, I'm just
going to read one more.
I don't know which
one it's going to be.
And then I'm going to
take questions, I guess.
So, think of questions.
All right.
I'm going to read this one
called Hoop, which gets back
to the illness theme, in away.
It's in two parts.
Hoop. God twirled across the face
of what cannot be named
since it was not moving.
God was momentum then, that
impatience with interruption,
stamping time's blanks
with its own image.
Now her theme will be that she
has escaped certain destruction,
that she is impossibly lucky.
This theme should be jaunty,
but slightly discordant,
coming in as it does, so late.
The character associated with
this theme should be dressed
in markedly old-fashioned
clothing, a hoop skirt perhaps,
while everyone else is in cut
offs, ready for the barbeque.
[ Applause ]
Okay, now does anyone have a --
could anyone have a question?
Yes?
>> Hi. I enjoyed your
comments very much.
In terms of the poetic act,
you talked about some stimulus,
some irritant, some mystery.
Okay, that's percolating
in your brain.
>> Rae Armantrout: Yeah.
>> What then happens?
Do you start a kind
of stream of words?
Do you write a bit, erase,
play with more words?
How does it come out
and how do you shape it?
>> Rae Armantrout: Well, I carry a
blank book around with me so that
when something does puzzle me,
irritate me, inspire me, whatever,
when I see or hear something
interesting, I make a note of it.
Or even if I read something
interesting,
I make a little note of it.
So, I'm kind of a magpie.
And then in the mornings I'll
sit and look over my notebook
and I'll see what has some resonance
and also what might go with what,
because although -- some
of the poems I read today
were actually in one piece.
It's more typical for my poems
to be divided into sections.
And those sections might
represent different moments,
different irritants or puzzles.
And so part of my process
is to see what looks
like it would juxtapose well
with something else
in an interesting way.
And then, yes, I do --
I do a lot of revision.
And often that amounts
to cutting things out.
Sometimes it amounts to
thinking of the right word,
but often it's cutting things out.
I have a couple of friends
I will send poems to,
and sometimes they will
say, no, or I don't get it.
And you know, I take that seriously.
But you do what you
can with it [laughs].
One of them's here in the
audience, so [laughs].
That's you.
>> You read to us, I think,
at least one prose poem.
>> Rae Armantrout: Two, yeah.
>> Two, okay.
And I'm wondering if you
could just comment on
or explain what your
conception of a prose poem is?
>> Rae Armantrout: Okay.
>> Specifically perhaps
differentiating a prose poem
from free verse?
>> Rae Armantrout: Okay.
Actually, now that I
think of it, I read three.
Well, if the sent -- it's
a matter of tone, for me.
If the sentences seem to be long
and discursive, if I'm going to want
to use phrases that -- where
there are a lot of words
that have an immediate punch, then
I turn that into a prose poem.
My poems that are poems tend
to have very short lines.
And I like each of those short lines
to have an interesting word or,
you know, something punchy in it.
So if it looks like I'm
not going to be able to do
that because it's just going
to be too normally discursive,
then I'll write it as a prose poem.
>> Thank you.
>> [inaudible].
>> Rae Armantrout: Oh, okay.
I didn't see you.
Yes?
>> Frank Clay, from Kansas.
Thank you for being here.
>> Rae Armantrout: Oh, thank you.
>> God bless you.
My question, as a poet
myself, is who's your audience?
I mean, do you define the audience?
Do you care if it's us
or are you really talking
about the people who
are walking around?
How do you write for an audience,
or is that important to you?
>> Rae Armantrout: Well, I think --
I don't know how this plays to a
crowd, but I think that a poet,
or at least I, write
first for myself.
And I mean that as I write as a
way of figuring out what I feel,
and figuring out what I think
if I can ever figure that out,
and writing into a problem.
And it's a way of talking myself
into and through something first.
So that's my first audience.
And then secondly, you know,
I write for people I know
who will read my poems, I know,
critically as well
as sympathetically.
And then, you know, lately I've
been reading to more people
who aren't poets and
whom I don't know.
And, you know, that's nice.
I don't think you can
really try to write in order
to please an unknown audience,
though, because if you do,
you're turning yourself into an
entertainer somehow, which --
I just don't think
it works that way.
I think that's counterproductive
somehow.
That's just my feeling.
>> Thank you.
>> Rae Armantrout: Okay.
>> Oh --
>> Rae Armantrout: You,
I guess you're next.
>> [Laughs].
Yes, the -- one of the authors
that almost won the Pulitzer
yielded the poetry author.
She also has a deadly disease.
>> Rae Armantrout: Oh,
I did not know that.
>> Lucia Perillo, and --
>> Rae Armantrout: Oh,
I'm sorry to hear that.
>> -- multiple sclerosis.
My question is, do you have a
-- do you have to write about --
she also writes about her disease.
And do you have to write
about a deadly disease to --
>> Rae Armantrout:
To win the Pulitzer?
>> -- to win the Pulitzer?
>> Rae Armantrout: Maybe [laughs].
>> And the second thing on that is
actually, her poetry is very earthy,
very female, like yours
on one level,
and also on the second level it's
also very complex, like yours.
And I guess the two questions are,
is that what the academics
are looking for and is
that what the masses
are looking for?
>> Rae Armantrout: Well, once again,
I don't claim to speak for either
of those groups specifically, but
I think if you look at the history
of the Pulitzer, you'll
see that it --
the person, the type of poet
who wins changes a
lot from year to year.
I mean, you know, you're
talking about two people who won
or were finalists in the same year,
which means they had the same
jury of three jury people.
But, you know, if you look
back two or three years,
you will see different patterns.
I mean, it changes all the time.
It depends on who the judges are.
Does it help to have
a deadly disease?
It probably does, I'm afraid.
I, you know, sorry [laughs].
Yes?
>> In one of the poems that you read
to us today, you used the language
of economics to describe
a deadly disease.
>> Rae Armantrout: Yeah.
>> And I'm just wondering, do you
consider that lexicon of finance
to be comparable or intertwined
with the lexicon of,
like, political spin?
And if so, could you talk
a little bit about that?
>> Rae Armantrout: Well, my
next book, which is coming
out in January, is
called Money Shot.
And that's a term that
actually comes from porn,
but there's not a whole
lot of porn in the book.
It has more to do with --
well, the pornography of money
in the last couple of years.
So, yeah, I pick up language.
Like I said, I'm sort of a
magpie, and I pick up language
from all sorts of sources,
the language of medicine,
the language of science,
the language of finance.
Whatever is, you know,
coming to the fore and is
of concern to me at the moment.
And, you know, we've been --
I actually brought poems from Money
Shot to read, but we're out of time.
So you would have seen more
of that had I done that.
>> Thank you.
I can't wait for your new book.
>> Rae Armantrout: [Laughs].
Yes?
>> You spoke about your illness, and
you write poetry about your illness,
listen, do you think an element
of truth in terms of a writer,
because you're writing about
something that's personal
that really, really
affects you that's physical,
do you think an element of truth
exists there when you're writing
about that as opposed
to other subjects?
>> Rae Armantrout: Well, my
experience often comes into my work.
It doesn't always come in directly.
I mean, it's not always
announced as my experience,
even when it's about illness.
My poems never begin and
so I have cancer and so.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> Rae Armantrout: Or, you know, but
I mean, other experiences of mine,
other than cancer, also, you know
-- say a problem I had with my son
or something, it could
enter into my work.
I just don't frame it
as autobiographical.
It -- the autobiographical
material enters on a par
with things I might
notice, you know,
looking at a bird, or something.
And, I don't really think that one's
view of oneself is any more accurate
than one's view of
the rest of the world.
It can be less accurate.
A lot of novelists
will tell you that.
Okay. One more?
Where are -- okay, one more.
>> Hi. I was wondering if you recall
the first time you were introduced
as a poet or you introduced
yourself as a poet?
And if you do recall,
how did that feel?
>> Rae Armantrout: It
feels icky [laughs].
I still try to avoid it, you know?
If I'm on an airplane and
I'm going to give a reading,
and the person next to me says:
What are you doing in Chicago?
I never say I'm giving
a poetry reading.
[inaudible].
I don't know.
I think that's just America.
I think in some other countries,
you know -- I hear, I hear tell,
that in Mexico or Iran,
that poets are celebrated.
But I think in the United
States there are a lot
of sort hostile parodies of
poetry out there in the media.
It's considered to be
sentimental or something, you know?
So, it's a hard thing to do.
I mean, I have to do it sometimes,
but it's not something you want
to usually come right out with
and have as the first thing
that you tell a stranger.
[Laughs].
>> Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[ Inaudible Audience Comment ]
>> Rae Armantrout: Yeah,
well, of course I am proud.
But it's not something that -- I'm
not proud of being proud [laughs].
But you should write poetry if you
have to or if you feel like it,
because, you know, it is rewarding.
I think it's very rewarding.
For one thing, poets
form a community.
I mean, even before I got any prizes
or even before I was published
by a university press back when
I was published by a small press,
I could go to most big
cities and stay with someone
because they were a poet, or they'd
go out to dinner with me, you know?
There is a kinship of poets.
And that's one of the
good things about it.
I think I should stop now
because I'm out of time.
[ Applause ]